hello and welcome to this video way - 34
really quickly
Tim 808 okay I'm going for another
Petrov and okay I'm really happy that
for that like that that project for the
Petrov project for Black Friday for like
Caruana that I also looked at all the
sidelines again these kind of things we
had really pace of you know stuff like
here I'm already having a really nice
position when you wanna shoot before and
why it has some problems here to get
this sorted but how exactly was it
played he'd be should f5 for strong I
had exactly the same thing in a game not
too long ago
and sometimes really a very beautiful
feature of those classical positions if
if white plays something really really
not great
you know sometimes get nice attacking
play early on I came here wow so how
does he survive all that ok night eggs
should be fine
okay
[Music]
hmm that is definitely something who
what do we do how do we win the Queen
age so on maybe Queen age four and it's
got Queen f3 but I'm not sure laughs
wait I mean it's not it's only given
that he plays that you know even though
Queen a3 looks very normal
many other things I mean that I believe
does not work at all I can just take
with the bishop and I'm threatening
Queen h3 made and I'm threatening do
this which is strategically
strategically basically lost you know
what how is he defending this cannot
cannot move so I'm getting on the second
with the rooks what is the quickest way
in this way probably I mean look at this
it's a defense to Queen g3 look aged six
I don't see any
rook h6 is gone almost local age six
like weenie - doesn't even defend
Queenie - doesn't even defend so then
this assessor's came over that took me
too long
yeah and threatening rook f3 pawn takes
to nursery-maid
and Queenie - I can do the same thing
and uncreate h2 at the end I'm winning
on f1 so yeah it was a there was a quick
one I had exactly the same game some two
weeks ago or something
when h3 was played and I did not go form
a played Bishop age 5 I think which
wasn't bad but this is just very strong
I mean the computer with perfect defence
gives me one point four or something no
ok here Knight takes Queen d1 Queen h4
Queen f3 I was singing Queen f3 is the
only somewhat interesting defense when I
wanted to play Bishop g6 claiming that
he does not have a good move which is
probably not wrong g6 also looks strong
I mean he simply has no development is
the problem and this is this this I
think Knight takes e4 just loses Bishop
takes h3 as a double question it takes
e4 is a double question mark okay
because that that is winning yeah you
know okay but this is a winning position
for black now you are engine wants to
play Knight f4
that's a [ __ ] funky move yeah I think
the funniest thing is a move like this
yeah where I'm taking and here white is
totally totally lost there you can never
untangle this okay so f3 happened and
now Ruby success is curtains there would
be one Queen g3 yeah it took me a moment
to recognize that this does not defend
of course because this is hanging still
yeah he still would need one move to
consolidate the whole thing
yeah the Bishop c5 line is quite quite
okay against the four Knights it's um
the the critical and the critical lines
there are
different not like this most critical is
probably taking only five here on the
next move at least from a direct point
of view if you want to try to refute
Bishop c5 which doesn't yeah feel like
it's possible but yeah some people also
just play like d3 something very simple
but that cannot endanger black um
yeah for sure okay guys thanks for
watching